welcome to a video on code tech
tutorials i want to show you
a little tip for video editing something
that's nice to have in your toolbox
and it's not something you want to do on
every video but there are definitely a
lot of situations where
knowing this sort of thing can save you
many hours of time
what i'm talking about here as you
probably know by the title of this video
is auto editing your video to cut
silences
it took me a while to find a tool to to
do this
eventually i found it on some form
somewhere but the tool is reaper reaper
is like a full audio editing suite
so let's go ahead and open this up i'll
walk you through the steps that i go
through
and i will mention that this seemed to
work better on the 32-bit version
this this process that i'm about to show
you had a problem when i went
through it on the 64-bit version so i'm
on the 32-bit version looks like there's
just been an update i'm not going to
grab that right now before doing a
tutorial though
so we're on 6.15. okay so what you do is
you bring in an audio
file or a video file rather say you're
recording
so you might have to if your video
format
does not come in here correctly you're
going to have to use something like
handbrake
to change the format of it and launching
handbrake here so you can see that
and break i'm not going to go through a
hand breaker so here we go
so some just various files i'm going to
go with whatever
this one is and i'm just going to show
you how i do this
okay so first of all we're going to drag
the file in to a new timeline here
it's going to build some peaks
okay so what you do is you click your
section of audio and
i'm not really going to get into all the
reaper controls i am not an expert with
reaper i will be the first to say
but you generally can click around and
select things
so you select this clip and then you go
up to actions
show action list there is no like
default hotkey or default button to do
this you've got to go to this
show action list and if we want to do
split or here we go
auto trim split items remove silence
so i guess remove silence if i type that
in there it is so i've
actually set a hotkey to it you can do
that if you want minus ctrl shift
s which is often like the uh save
but whatever ctrl shift s so anyway you
can find in this actions click on it
press run and it brings up this little
toolbox about how you want to auto trim
so there is a threshold for loudness
i've noticed i don't know for me like
negative 37 seems pretty good
but the further you go down on this the
the more it's going to pick up
of silence so usually you want to figure
out a good ratio
negative 37 tends to be what i like but
if i wanted to pick up
more stuff if it's cutting out too much
i might change it to like negative 40
i might try negative 39 first
we're going to stick with 37 for this
episode for this uh demo and episode
hi i rester i don't know what this is
i've never used this
um yeah i'm not sure maybe i'll look it
up and put it
in like a flag but i've never had to use
it does something with the volume
obviously okay and it says we have an
option to ignore
sciences shorter than you put a number
here i think the default is 200
but i put 400 usually
but let's stick with 200 and you see
there's a
yeah this stuff literally does what it
says makes non-cyanoclips no shorter
than so you can set that time
we got a leading pad and a trailing pad
of when it
uh starts and ends these clips and you
can have a fade
here if you want now to trade in between
the pads
and auto adjust snap peak offset for the
first
whatever 100 um i usually leave this on
i'm not really sure what this does but
you can play around with these options
and try different things now
this uh these bottom three options are
rather important so if you want the
silence
you want the area to just be blank then
you can click this
i'm trying to think of how to explain
that in a way that makes sense but
basically if you uncheck this
it compresses all your video down and
makes it shorter
if you do check this it preserves the
timing so it'll cut the silenced area
but it'll just leave a big gap
so usually you want to condense it down
but it depends
and there's some other options here
which i don't use so
we're just keeping it with this split
and remove silence not checking any of
those and we're going to hit process
and there it has finished processing and
now it caps out at about
8 32. so it cut a good bit of silence
out of that video
but now this is just in the editor it
hasn't rendered it out so the next thing
you have to do is
render your results and the way you do
that
is you go to let's see show action list
again here
and then we're going to look for i think
it's just called render
render project to disk that's what it is
control
alt r is the default shortcut but render
project to disk so we just hit run on
that it brings up a little menu about
what we want to do
now here's some important things to get
correct here
set your directory i'm going to put it
to a render folder
give your file name so you can see here
it's looking at a wave
because reaper is really used for audio
but we can render this as a video
instead by going down to the format here
changing this to video ffmpeg
and then i usually change this format
from webm
to this qt slash move
mp4 this seems to be the pretty standard
one
and i don't touch any of the other
settings here you can play around with
them if you want
but it seems to render fine when i do
this
and then you just hit render file this
will take a good while
but what will come out the other end in
this folder that you selected with this
name and then dot move
so yeah it'll be right there when it's
all done
you'll have a new video with all the
silence cut out but otherwise will be
pretty much the same of course it went
through this whole
encoding and formatting thing so maybe
it'll lose a little bit of frame rate or
something but
you might be able to play around with
settings and get that better if
necessary
so i'm going to hit render well it's
probably just going to take forever
yeah yeah this is going to take well it
says about 10 minutes
and we are back it has completed so it
has a few options here you can go
show and explore or just launch file i'm
going to go show it explorer
should take me to the old render folder
and there's there it is you can see it's
6.31 gigs in about eight minutes
let's go look at the original the
original one is
about two gigs so it did increase the
size
but this original one is also let's just
check the length with a quick play here
looks like this is a league of legends
match about 20 minutes
and it cut it to 18 minutes so it cut
off about 12 minutes
let's just say play is this actually the
same video i got to make sure yeah it is
okay so this is like a league of legends
match all right so cut it down to eight
minutes
which hey might be cool it might be all
the action scenes or something in this
video
obscure thing like it took me a while to
figure out how to do this
i remember i think i found
just some random old post that someone
said how to do it but beyond that i
searched and searched this topic
and could not find it so i hope this
helps someone figure this out that has
been searching for a really long time
because it's a really nice
trick to have in the toolbox and this
was the one way i could figure out to do
it
so i'll just do a quick recap let's
reset this
just a little control z action so all
you do is you drag in your file
convert it if you need if it doesn't
like it
then you select your audio file go to
actions show action list
look for silence or remove silence
you'll find it run that
set these options as you like process
then after you process
yeah just hit oh you go to actions and
you go to project to disk
there it is render project disk run that
and this is the really important part
make sure you get the output set up how
you want make sure you change this to
ffmpeg
and change this format to move to
mp4 i don't know maybe you do want to
vitamin it just depends on what you want
but i always do this in before one it
seems to be good for
youtube and other editors as far as i
know
all right well thank you guys for
watching special shout out to my patrons
on patreon
for helping me making this content for
you guys
feel free to join over there if you like
link down below
appreciate all of you peace out
matt from code tech tutorials over and
out please let me know what you think
down below
and feel free to share like and
you